I've actually talked to some of the
energy folks from Massachusetts point
blank on this out of their state
legislature and their goal is is to make
Massachusetts more energy renewable
friendly by importing renewable energy
from other states so my statement's name
is so what you want us to do is put up
more wind towers in our state because
you don't want to have wind towers in
your state and then you stop using these
other forms of energy but make us cover
our whole landscape with wind towers so
you don't have to look at them that's
really what their plan is at the end of
the day when I talk to them about
switching from let's say home heating
oil to burning cleaner natural gas
they'll say well we're trying to just
get rid of all carbons entirely but in
the meantime our plan is for decades and
decades and decades to keep using home
eating oil they're not really serious
about all these issues they're they're
just trying to be able to make everyone
think that they really are but look at
what they're really doing and that makes
a big difference there
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the junior senator from the great state
of Oklahoma James Lankford Senator
Lankford welcome to the Reuben report
hey very good to see you good to be on
with you another conversation I'm
looking forward to chatting with you
because I mentioned to you right before
we started that we had your Governor
Kevin Stitt on about a month and a half
ago and I'm going to start with the same
exact question because I don't think
people know a lot about Oklahoma so if
someone says to you what's going on over
in Oklahoma what do you tell them
freedom and liberty that's what's
happening in Oklahoma actually is four
million great people who uh skip away
away from tornadoes occasionally we get
a bad rep for that but there's a job
opportunities there's lots of people
working that are there it's a really
great community and I have people that I
talk to all the time that are from other
places in the country and they moved I
will never move away because of the
people that are here and so it's a
pretty remarkable state right it's a
Left Coast calls flyover Terror
territory but we're glad they just fly
over us because it's a it's a great
place to be able to live what kind of
influx are you guys getting in these
last two years you know everyone talks
about all the Cali and New York people
going to Texas going to Florida going to
Tennessee but you guys are getting a
pretty decent influx as well right we
are actually I talked to uh real estate
agents around Oklahoma and I'll always
ask them who are you selling houses to
right now and they're telling me they're
selling houses to people from Washington
state from Oregon from California from
Minnesota from all these states are
moving into Oklahoma and my first
comment to them is are you checking
voter ID with them before you sell my
house right which by the way they can't
do that's not legal but then then the
second statement they make is oh no
these are the people we want to be able
to move they're fleeing from all of that
in those areas of the country and
they're coming to a place that's more do
you think people are getting it because
you know there always is that concern
I've told the story on the show many
times when I moved to Florida last year
and I'd be walking my dog and people
would come up and say hi Oh you're the
new neighbor and they say where are you
from I'd say Cali they'd freak out for a
second and then you know I'd have a
Florida man shirt or hat or I'd show a
picture of me and the governor or
something and then they're okay but but
the ogs there is that concern right that
you guys have done it right in Oklahoma
and you don't want that mucked up that's
correct and again we're open to
everybody coming all political
Persuasions people talk about Oklahoma
is a very red State all 77 counties uh
vote a republican the last three
presidential elections so it's we we get
that reputation somewhat but we've got
lots of people lots of different
University of opinion on that and that's
a good thing for us to continue to be
able to drive that but we also want to
be able to maintain the culture that we
have a freedom of opportunity a business
starts of low taxes I mean those are all
things that we want to continue to be
able to maintain and protect energy you
guys must be pretty proud of uh the
policies when it came to covid and and
not crushing the economy and killing all
the all the schools and all of that
stuff
yep schools stayed open churches stayed
open businesses stayed open and we had
we had that uh a few week time period
there at the very beginning uh in 2020
where things were closed down like the
rest of the country and then reopen
rapidly on it to say hey this is a
terrible idea and uh got things back
open again and it showed the real
difference there and the way our
businesses bounced back are you shocked
how different the blue and red states
have become I mean obviously there's
there's always been a difference in
policy between Democrats and Republicans
but how the last couple years have
really Unearthed something that is
causing people to flee certain States
and go to certain other states and and
it really doesn't go the other way I'm
guessing you're not losing a lot of
Oklahomans who are on their way to Cali
no
no we we don't have a lot of Oklahomans
that are packing up in fact if you want
to this is kind of the running joke that
people have in Oklahoma if you want to
rent a U-Haul truck a one-way rental to
California you could almost get that for
free uh because it's so cheap to go
towards California with a one-way truck
but if you're coming out of it it's
really expensive to be able to come the
other way because they're looking for
more people to drink so no we're not
surprised there are very few people
leave Oklahoma they come to Oklahoma
we're grateful to be able to have great
families we have a lot of veterans uh
that as they serve at Tinker Air Force
Base or Fort Sill or all kinds of places
are Enid around our state they'll serve
there and then 10 years later they'll
Circle back to Oklahoma and retire
coming back to Oklahoma because they
just love the Patriotic environment I
don't know if you've seen the meme but
there's a really hilarious meme of Gavin
Newsom working at U-Haul number one
U-Haul salesman of uh the last three
years I think
he is he's he's a good exporter of
things California because people are
leaving his state so yeah exactly um can
you talk a little bit about uh just the
economy and and what you guys are doing
on the energy side of things because
that's the type of thing that I think
sort of translates to people that don't
live in Oklahoma that are that are
watching right now
yeah one of the lowest unemployment
rates in the country is in Oklahoma so
we have very high employment in our
state uh we are an energy state but we
are truly all the above energy State
people know us as an oil and gas state
but we do oil and gas we do a little bit
of coal in the Eastern side of our state
we have a lot of wind power uh sing the
song Oklahoma where the wind comes
sweeping down the plane uh we've taken
that wind and we've harnessed it for
power and electricity we use it not only
in our state but we export it to other
states as well we have solar power we
have hydro electric uh in the eastern
part of our state we have geothermal
we're in all the above energy State and
it's always funny to me I'll have some
of my liberal colleagues in DC started
lecturing me about oil and gas and I'll
say to them let's look up right now your
portfolio of energy usage in your state
and let's compare it to mine I'd be glad
to be able to lay Oklahoma side by side
with Massachusetts for instance because
we're using clean natural gas to heat
our homes home heating oil in their
basement which might as well be burning
a lump of coal in their basement to be
able to heat their homes on it there's
no comparison we're so much cleaner in
our energy development than the
Northeast is but yet they're always the
one trying to be able to Pile in new
requirements on us so we've already done
that in our state and we're very proud
to have so many energy jobs and such
great energy diversity so when you're
talking to a colleague let's say a
senator in Massachusetts maybe Elizabeth
Warren just using her as an example and
you say Hey you know we're doing it
right here and we've we've got this
diversification of energy you guys don't
have that yet you seem to want to
destroy the energy sector uh did they
respond are you able to have that
conversation do they realize how
misguided the policies are well they
don't like the comparison side by side
but I've actually talked to some of the
energy folks from Massachusetts point
blank on this out of their state
legislature and their goal is is to make
Massachusetts more energy renewable
friendly by importing renewable energy
from other states so my statement to
them is so what you want us to do is put
up more wind towers in our state because
you don't want to have wind towers in
your state and then you stop using these
other forms of energy but make us cover
our whole landscape with wind towers so
you don't have to look at them that's
really what their plan is at the end of
the day when I talk to them about
switching from let's say home heating
oil to burning cleaner natural gas
they'll say well we're trying to just
get rid of all carbons entirely but in
the meantime our plan is for decades and
decades and decades to keep using home
eating oil they're not really serious
about all these issues they're they're
just trying to be able to make everyone
think that they really are but look at
what they're really doing and that makes
a big difference there what kind of
tension do you have as a as a state that
has you know you've got the Renewables
you've got the traditional energy
sources you know the federal government
obviously wants you to go in One
Direction you don't want to put people
out of work how do you manage all that
well a couple couple things in that we
have a lot of manufacturing mistake
because we have some of the lowest
lowest electricity prices in the country
so we literally have manufacturers
moving to Oklahoma for cheaper
electricity because we produce so much
electricity from such a diverse
portfolio of it so that makes a big
difference on it the other parts of the
jobs that go with that because we'll
have a lot of jobs that are created in
the internet energy market and in
manufacturing because of that that's why
we have such a low unemployment rate in
our in our state so it does make a
difference in our own economy uh one of
the things that I talked to Governors
stid about that he he was very fired up
but I really wanted to focus on was some
of the tensions existing around what's
going on with the Native American
communities and law disparity and all of
this stuff uh how how is that all
shaking out right now and your position
on all that so yeah we've got a pretty
wide diversity of opinion on that we
have 4 million Oklahomans about seven
percent of our state is Native American
it's a very high percentage for any
other state on it uh we now have six
tribes that have a special uh allotment
from the Supreme Court called the mcgirt
decision uh that mcgird decision said
that the federal government has to be
the one to actually prosecute major
crimes in the state for those particular
tribes and in those tribal areas uh it's
not small and a lot of people across the
country may not track this they may see
Indian reservations in other states
where it's only tribal members live in
that area that's not so in Oklahoma
Oklahoma we're very integrated on it you
would literally drive through airs and
not have any idea if this is tribal area
or non-tribal area or you may have one
house that's a travel member and next
door to them is a non-travel member on
it because of our just our integration
of where we are as a state this has
dramatically shifted what's happening in
law enforcement in our state where a
police officer doesn't know whether they
can prosecute a crime or that has to to
be the FBI coming to be able to do it
and has created quite a bit of chaos and
stir while the tribes are trying to step
up and do some things we have unequal
Justice currently in our state and this
is something that has to be resolved
we're going to have a federal solution
but it's going to have to have all of
those tribes agree our state agree and
the federal delegation to also be able
to agree on this to be able to get some
Solutions in the meantime we'll have
individuals and we've already had an
occasion where an individual had
multiple DUIs but was let off every
single time and then that same person
runs over and murders a five-year-old
there's no way to explain to some Dad
hey it's because this particular
individual was tribal and so they can
get off with it when a non-tribal member
cannot that that can't be so we've got
to be able to have equal justice and
process and we've got to have some way
for law enforcement to be able to
prosecute this so that something came
out of the Supreme Court several years
ago we're still working to be able to
get to resolution on this and we have to
get to keep working until we get to
resolution yeah are you trying to get it
back to to the Supreme Court I'm
actually not even sure technically how
that happens
so there's actually a case that's
already come back to the Supreme Court
called the Castro it started with mcgirt
and then it went back it was called
Castro where to second case and then it
helped Define uh for instance if a
non-travel member commits a crime on a
tribal member where does that go does I
go to the FBI or does I go to the State
uh the Supreme Court ruled in the second
case well that one goes to the state so
you can see the chaos that's going on in
trying to be able to prosecute through
individuals now you got to know the
perpetrator of a crime before you know
who can actually go through and
investigate and prosecute that Trump if
you knew the perpetrator was who would
have prevented the crime in the first
place on it so it's it's a very
difficult process so yes it may go back
to the Supreme Court I'm doubtful that
it will fully the Supreme Court what
we've got to do is get a piece of
legislation through the federal
government through Congress and have
agreement with the tribes agreement with
the state in agreement with the federal
legislature to be able to resolve this
differences and try to figure out how to
be able to do prosecutions in the main
time all of our courts are overwhelmed I
don't know if you track all this but
federal courts don't typically handle
murder cases for instance that's a
pretty rare thing for a federal
jurisdiction to handle a murder case
that's a State Crime 57 of all the
federal murder cases in the country are
in one small part of Southeast Oklahoma
57 in the whole country of the federal
murder cases are just in that one small
section that's not the federal
jurisdiction that's not what they handle
typically they don't have the expertise
to be able to do it and they're
overwhelmed with it and we've got
occasions where if a car of a car so
just to be clear though it's not because
you have a crazy amount of murders it's
because of this decision
yeah that's correct it's because the
federal government typically doesn't
have that many murder cases so all that
they have the vast majority of the cases
that they have at all are in Oklahoma
because of this mcgird decision and if
they're Prosecuting those murder cases
rightfully so that also means if so
someone stole a car from a tribal member
no one's Prosecuting them and so now
they're just victims of crime that no
one's Prosecuting because no one has the
jurisdiction or the time to go get it
that can't be so yeah this is why it's
so important that our state and our
tribes and the federal government work
together to be able to resolve this
because we've got to have equal justice
for every single person we're not at
odds with each other uh the tribes and
the state and individuals we're four
million neighbors we've got to just
figure this part out but it's a mess
right it really sounds like it I mean
equal protection under the law it's one
of the most American uh ideas that there
is and uh hopefully hopefully it works
out let me ask you a little bit about
just DC in general and being a senator
having to go to DC which is obviously
very very different than when you're
when you're back home in Oklahoma
the Red Wave didn't happen so you
probably thought maybe you were gonna
you know have a little more power the
Republicans at this point like what's
the General State of things in DC right
now
well right now it's a mess because of
what's going on with the Appropriations
process uh and you're right we we all
expected the Red Wave would happen
we hope for that prayed for that quite
frankly that didn't happen and we're
still going throughout the process of
the whys and the what's of all of that
but that didn't happen around the
country so it's not just uh praying for
me a little more power on it it's a
little bit of Sanity into the process
you realize in the Senate there's been
no oversight hearings on immigration
we've got two million people illegally
crossing the board in the past year it's
about to get even worse in the Senate
it's not even holding hearings like
don't even look at that just ignore it
that's that's crazy to be able to have
that and so we want to be able to get
that all the fiscal sanity that we need
to be able to bring back into the
dialogue right now of how we're going to
handle the Appropriations process which
is in the shambles right now or even how
we're gonna handle spending spending
continues to be able to go up Democrats
don't want to even discuss that have
hearings on it to be able to talk long
term about entitlements what's going to
happen to be able to stabilize our
spinning or to get us back into balance
no dialogue so for Republicans to come
back in the lead in the Senate was
really a shift in leadership in the
Committees and an opportunity to bring
some hearings up into say let's talk
about debt and deficit let's talk about
immigration how to be able to solve
these problems let's talk about how
we're going to handle complicated issues
that are currently being ignored that
are really important to the American
people like the economy and how we're
going to actually bring down inflation
but instead it's just move along ignore
that that's the frustrating part do you
think that if the Republicans had got
the Senate that they would have actually
accomplished some of the things that
you're talking about I think one of the
frustrations that a lot of people have
that that care about politics and pay
attention to this I think there's a
feeling sort of like certainly amongst
my audience and me personally like the
Republicans are obviously way better
than the Democrats the Democrats have
lost their mind but like you shouldn't
expect a lot from the Republicans and
they're probably going to let you down
do you think you guys would have had a
chance to to actually do some things or
do you think you know the Republicans do
have Congress you think they're going to
get some stuff done
yeah so there's a couple of things there
if we'd have won the Senate back one we
could have controlled Biden's nominees
uh he's putting in really radical
Progressive nominees we have been able
to block a few of those but now there'll
be no way to block any of them he'll
have 51 votes and he will be able to
rapidly move all his nominations through
so yes we could have done that and
controlled that we could have managed
the different issues that are coming up
on hearings we still have to deal with
the Democrat White House and so just
passing everything and saying that we're
going to get that passed to Democrat
White House is not true but it gives us
a lot more leverage and if you want to
talk about a big issue the 2017 tax
policy that happened when we did the tax
cuts in jobs act some of those areas
expire in 2026 so in the next two years
we're going to be doing major tax
negotiations it would have made a world
of difference to have Republicans as the
lead negotiator on that tax piece than
is going to be to have Democrats as the
lead negotiators on those tax areas so
yes I do think it would have made a big
difference but by the way not all
Republicans think alike uh it's always
funny everybody elects their republican
from their state right and they'll say
to me why doesn't everybody function
like you and I'll say because not
everyone lives in Oklahoma and thinks
like Oklahomans not only everyone's as
conservatives I am there are other
states that are not as conservative of
ours and we have a pretty diverse
opinion about that and Republicans tend
to be able to do not formation they fly
like eagles they don't fly in formation
all the time it's like a bunch of
Libertarians you get them around the
table and they argue about the driver's
license issue for about three hours that
met everybody goes home Angry I think
that's pretty much pretty much how it
works I'm wondering uh since as a new
Floridian I do see this place that I'm
in as sort of the blueprint for a free
America and I know that uh Governor this
actually just a few months ago I was at
an event where he got a few about 10
Governors together that's where I met
Governors did for the first time uh
where they're starting to coordinate a
little bit more sort of outside of the
federal government and I wonder what you
think of that just conceptually that the
red states are kind of starting to do
some things and not worrying always hey
what is by I didn't think about this or
the federal government think about this
yeah they shouldn't have to welcome to
federalism that's how our system was set
up actually each state was supposed to
compete with the state next door and we
get better in that competition we should
be doing legislation that other states
look at our state and go wow that's
really good legislation we should do
that in our state and so that
competition actually helps us for
Republican Governors to be able to get
together and to be able to say what are
you doing that's actually helping your
employment your tax policy what are you
doing that's being able to help in
different areas great continue that idea
our Attorneys General have done that for
a long time and that's been very
effective for Attorneys General Across
the Nation to be able to swap ideas and
be able to file suits against the
federal government to be able to push
back on that encroachment in a way
uniquely State Attorneys General can
that I as a senator can't file suit
against these different issues like a
state can and so when the states
cooperate together it makes a big
difference that's how our system was set
up uh I asked basically all my guests
this question I wish I could get more
Democrats on task on this question but
uh they don't want to show up we do ask
what do you think has happened to the
Democrat Party I mean this is not the
Democrat Party I was a Democrat for much
of my life this is certainly not the
Democrat Party of JFK or of Daniel
Patrick Moynihan Ed Koch Etc the the
sort of old school Blue Dog liberal that
you probably had a decent amount of them
in Oklahoma it seems to be seems to be
gone at this point
yeah the the party is so dramatically
shifted on this and in Oklahoma I have
kind of a running joke that I have with
folks to say President Reagan got
Democrats in Oklahoma to vote Republican
president Obama got Democrats in
Oklahoma to re-register as a republican
because there was such a massive shift
that's happened but if you go back just
15 years ago every Statewide elected
official in Oklahoma was a Democrat
that's 15 years ago it's not that long
ago there's been this dramatic shift
that has occurred in the National
Democrat Party and you feel it in other
ways in our states with re-registration
as people that have been lifelong
Democrats have said I don't even
recognize this party and they may be
shift into independent or they may be
shifting to Republican but they're
shifting away from Democrats to say I
don't follow these social policies I
don't follow this crazy spending policy
I don't follow these tax policies on it
they look at the different issues they
look at quite frankly the open border
and they say I'm not all in on that what
in the world is that and so they just
can't follow where Democrats are going
and quite frankly the D.C Democrats
continue to be able to race each other
farther to the left and there's this
constant push over and over again to see
who can out left the next person and
they're just racing away from the
American people well my follow-up to
that always is do you think they believe
it when you when you're talking to your
Democrat colleagues uh do you think that
they believe all of this stuff worked
that the big spending works that the
giant government programs work etc or is
it that they're just in the rat race now
and they can't turn back
it's a bit of both on that I do run into
some True Believers that are here in the
Senate and I also run into some folks
saying hey I'll just get barbecued if I
don't go along with this but I'm not
sure this is a great idea
um so it just kind of depends from
person to person on it but there is a
huge push for them to continue to go
farther and farther and farther left and
I think it's it's the remaking of the
country it's this celebration of our
country was evil and its founding and
its history and its laws and so we're
going to remake the nation in our image
into what we always wanted to be able to
be but she's never been she's always
been a Nation about individuals having
Freedom all together and committed to
each other and uh so but that that's not
where they're headed Senator I got one
more for you the one that I'm sure you
don't want to answer uh Republicans are
going to have to pick a president
they're going to have to all you know
follow somebody obviously Trump has
announced there's a feeling that
DeSantis will announce there's to me
there's a actually pretty great crop of
people I think Nikki Haley Tim Scott
like there's really a decent group there
which you don't see that kind of bench
with the Democrats what do you see as
the the future of all of this I'm sorry
you're breaking up I can't hear you
anymore
yeah the the party's going to have to
decide I mean honestly you just list off
a bunch of folks Mike Pence Mike Pompeo
they're also out there there's there's a
whole big long list of great Republicans
that are out there that are good thought
leaders that the nation's going to have
to be able to make a decision on which
way they're going to go on this and uh
we'll see when the primaries actually
begin obviously it's already it's
already begun president Trump has
already announced he's going to run
again but by the time we get into early
next year we're really going to know the
whole field if somebody's not in by this
summer they're not going to be able to
get in but there are a lot of folks that
I think we're considering it or looking
at this to try to figure out if they can
do the fundraising and they can get out
there and be able to share the message
I've said this publicly so I'll say it
to you and to your audience again in
Oklahoma when I talk to folks about half
the folks I talk to that are
conservative will say they love
president Trump they love the way he
speaks they love his policies they want
him to run again and about half the
folks will say to me I love president
Trump as policies I don't like him as a
messenger I wish there was someone else
that had those policies that didn't have
that way of actually speaking and acting
and reacting to people so it's we're
pretty divided even as a state in
Oklahoma it'll be interesting to be able
to see how many other states are divided
as well there's been very strong support
for the Trump policies because we saw
what he did for immigration we saw what
he did for the economy we saw what it
did for our national standing on the
world stage so people are very grateful
for that but they're divided on whether
they're going to keep going on that
again so again we're going to solve that
as Republicans to be able to put up our
nominee what I want to have us do is to
be able to win at the end and be able to
articulate what real conservative
policies are and it's fascinating to me
the number of college students that I
talk to nowadays that are that are young
conservatives that will want to talk to
me about Ronald Reagan and they're
intrigued with a republican who won 49
states they're like how did that happen
how did a republican win 49 states in an
election in his re-election even and to
be able to get that and so they're
fascinated with that jovial outgoing
conservative thought that's Winsome and
winning people over on that and I get
that culturally we've got to be able to
figure out what direction we're going to
go but as a party I want to continue to
not just burn Heretics I want to make
converts because I think these
conservative principles actually do work
and help people in every race every
Community every background it really
truly does lift all boats and so let's
let's go tell the message and let some
Messengers out there go duke it out
Senator I appreciate your time I hope we
can do it again perhaps in person in
Oklahoma because I do think even though
they call them flyover states they are
important States and uh that would be
fun you know I actually land in Oklahoma
so I know it's possible to be able to
land there and not just fly over it and
if we get there I can take you to some
really great barbecue places uh and we
can sit down and have a great visit
right on awesome well I appreciate it
thanks for your time if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell